welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and after a massive hiatus due to the
pandemic the walking dead is back with
its season finale
now throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the entry
as well as our thoughts on where things
could be going in the future
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
the episode yet then i highly recommend
that you turn off now
make sure you drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this every day with that other way
thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the video okay so the
finale
very much deals with the culmination of
the whisper of war
alpha is dead and the last time we saw
beta he was descending on the abandoned
hospital that the survivors had set up
as their base
we pick up in the midst of this with the
undead at the door
but there is hope in the unity that the
four central locations have
i love the little fist thing that
gabriel does to count the kingdoms
and throughout history fists have been
used as a symbol of defines
now it's been a long time since episode
15 dropped
and you may have forgotten exactly what
was going on
basically yeah quick catch up there are
several survivors out in the wilderness
looking for forces that will help them
and alongside maggie princess was also
discovered
kelly told carol that her superpower was
her going off on her own
but like she learned no one is an island
and we are all stronger together
this is exemplified in eugene's ark in
this entry
as initially he seems completely
defeated however
ezekiel helps him find his strength and
pulls him back on his feet
i think this episode definitely feels
like it's about community
and even though they're living on
borrowed time you really get the feeling
of the show's heart
which i felt was missing throughout the
prior season this aesthetic of trying to
bring everyone together
massively plays into the ending of the
episode and though we don't see this
group
as much as we should the way things end
it makes it seem like they somewhat
completed their goal
what's around the corner we don't know
yet but i'll discuss that later in the
video
now there's more family talk here than a
fast and furious film
and i think seeing lydia building her
relationship with carol
is a mark of just how far she's come
she's not looking for another mother
but she's found one in her and a father
figure in negan
i have to say i miss these guys and it
is great to see them back
now negan gives lydia her mother's mask
and says that he's pretty much taking
the easy way out
lydia has this option too and she could
easily blend in with the undead
but unlike him she chooses to stay
behind with the community
now negan of course comes back later in
the episode
but we'll talk about that in just a bit
now the plan is to lead the undead off
the edge of a cliff
and leave the death stranding and a lot
of the entry
centers around the group formulating a
plan before they enact it
that that death stranding pun was was
one of my worst i'm sorry
now it really feels like they come
before the storm for a lot of the
episode
and even when they come face to face
with the dead they tend to use their
wits more than their fists
with the guts of the walkers they once
more create camouflage for themselves
and though this has been done several
times in the show before
i don't think it's ever been this tense
never before have we seen the survivors
going against an
army like this and though isn't balls to
the wall action
it's still a thrilling watch using
arches for cover
the brave survivors head out into the
herd and managed to draw them away from
the hospital
however the whisperers managed to stab
beatrice which makes her scream out in
agony
it's heartbreaking seeing carol having
to leave her behind because the duty
that she has
means more than her death now it's at
this point that lydia arrives with her
mother's mask
and says that she wants to help playing
the talking head song burning down the
house
they lead the horde away from the
hospital whilst taking out the
whisperers as they try and sabotage
their plan
i really hope that this was some
foreshadowing that would end up with the
survivors
burning down the house as beta thought
he was speaking to some
talking walker heads unfortunately
though the show runners don't love crap
puns as much as i do
and it's just a random song it's here
where things really pick up
and the whisperers manage to shut down
the wagon whilst they storm the hospital
this forces gabriel to remain behind to
buy the other's time
just before they're about to kill him
maggie arrives
and elsewhere we see that negan has
actually gone after beta
he knocks him on his back and daryl
stabs him in his eyes
in what is a completely brutal scene the
character begins to hallucinate
that he's being surrounded almost like
jesus and it is quite a fitting farewell
he's unmasked the negan recognizes him
and asks if daryl knows who he is
he replies yeah nobody but as we know
the character was actually a rock star
before the world went to hell
and one of his lps was even spotted in
fear the walking dead
is a cool little easter egg now due to
the wagon being dismantled
someone has to sacrifice themselves and
lead the walkers over the edge
whilst lydia was originally going to do
this carol takes over this herself
and this again calls back to her
superpower being her ability to go off
on her own
she's just about to end her life however
she's saved by lydia
who of course embraces her as a mother
figure now and we watch as the horde all
walk off the edge of the cliff
like when he used to get bored in
lemmings and and send everyone to their
death
lydia tosses the mask over the edge too
symbolically
throwing her mother's hold over her
along with the horde
and the survivors are finally free with
a looming threat over their heads now
gone
in the end maggie is reunited with the
group properly
namely judith and i actually love to see
her become her maternal figure
now that michonne has stepped away
maggie of course delivered judith from
lori
so there is a lot that they can do here
now we still don't know who her
companion is
but make sure you let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
negan has remained behind too and when
this season first started
i never thought i'd actually like him as
much as i do but at the moment he's by
far my favorite character
finally we get carolyn daryl and as we
now know the two are gonna go off and do
their own thing together
at some point in a spin-off show now
this won't actually be coming out until
2023
so there's still a lot of things that
could happen in between now
and then we don't have very many plot
details just yet
but we do know that it will
predominantly be a road show that
centers around them going
out into the world to see who's left
norman reedus said the pair will
encounter a revolving group of people
so every week we'll have a different
cast of characters that they bump into
this sort of monster of the week thing
will allow for some really big name
actors to come on board
and do stand-alone work so you know
there's a lot of potentials that could
happen here
now elsewhere we see connie waking up in
the woods
completely broken and she collapses on
the floor before being found by virgil
it's sort of like history repeating
itself and though virgil
might not be the bad guy that he once
was i'm still really worried for connie
because she's in a very vulnerable
position i think virgil will wrestle
with his inner nature
and he could even be tempted to turn
back to his old ways
because of the way that he picks connie
up he actually has the potential to
paint himself out
as a good samaritan i kind of got those
sort of vibes from him here
and in the story of the samaritan he of
course comes across someone in trouble
and helps them out now that could mean
that he's actually going to redeem
himself
and will heal her or like we said turn
into a villain once more
i guess we will see but the episode ends
on a huge cliffhanger
that actually lets us know where the
show is heading from now on
eugene and co arrive at their
destination to find it seemingly
abandoned
but rather than turning back they decide
to press on and find more like-minded
people
he really is one horny dude and just as
they have a moment of levity
they're surrounded by some power ranger
looking dudes who seem just like
something out of a time travel movie
now this is actually the army of the
commonwealth who have been teased for
quite a while now
the commonwealth are actually a massive
community that's made up of 50 000
survivors and in this infrastructure
they've built a massive base of shops
commodities and pretty much got things
back to the way that they were before
the apocalypse
people have jobs there's banks barbers
and it's basically all the good things
we had before
2020 now though you would think that
this would be amazing
as with all societies there's a
structure in it in which the higher ups
rule over the lower classes
and they can often be corrupt and
selfish the commonwealth view themselves
as superior to all
and this means that they don't really
accept others in
heck these soldiers are intimidating
enough as it is
and without that they're gonna be
getting a warm welcome now this weekend
also brings with it the release of the
walking dead world beyond
which could even be taking place in the
commonwealth itself
i haven't had a chance to check out the
show just yet but do you know that it's
set ten years after the apocalypse
in a time when society has pulled itself
together and learned to live alongside
the walkers
i don't want to go too in depth on it as
like i said i haven't seen it
and i could say something completely
idiotic but
let me know in the comments below if
it's connected as i'm sure there are
definitely some avenues here that they
can go
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoy this video and want
something else to watch then definitely
check out our breakdown of the boys
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over the latest episode and point
out all the easter eggs and things that
you missed
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more don't forget we're
also giving away three copies of the
marvel phase one box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
with notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on the discord
server linked in the description
or our heavy spoilers on twitter thanks
for making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
so